relive it died what did but was alive
brother Eddie gonna show you all the
deets also long they can peace be unto
you we have another exciting show for
you every week we have an exciting show
if you would exciting people who join us
this week on the Dean show my next guest
who was with the likes singing with
working with Run DMC Sinead O'Connor
alexander o'neal and many many other
famous songwriters and singers but today
he's on the dean sho Abdul role to tell
us his story and his journey to Islam
right back on the Dean show Allah
there's only one word and Muhammad is
His Messenger a la la
ha there's only one bad and Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum walaikum Salaam please be
with you te Burton so how are you how
are you I'm didn't um not too bad thank
you thank you for being with us here on
benicia it's the pleasure to be here now
the time is short we love to get people
that nice taste so they can continue
coming back and they can continue to
look into Islam and we clear a lot of
the misconceptions we have a lot of
scholars who come on and we also give
the people a treat people who come from
other favs they used to be Christian
like you were and people who have had
many different experiences and you used
to be with the likes of working with Run
DMC these are like the founders or like
the icons or the originator of hip-hop
mmm-hmm let's start from there tell us
of your days when you were back with
some of the likes of run DMC Sinead
O'Connor who was it out whoa what it was
I was working for a record company back
in the day and what we did was we
actually bought the rights from
Alexander our nails tracks it was fake
and criticized yeah and we met him in
the studio we've done the remixes it was
a very nice it's very nice man you know
yet so long some issues but we're not
going to go into any of that here bye it
was nice working with him Run DMC was
was a remix yes and his wife Justine
Simmons yeah who I don't know how to
describe her vocals but I think I don't
think she did any more work after that
particular track yeah and that was very
short-lived that new one experience
there and the same with Sinead O'Connor
that was a remix yeah I did say I didn't
actually get to to actually physically
work with her it was just due to remix
of a track it was called a thousand
mirrors yeah which it was a beautiful
and well written track and that handled
the remixed I did was more received so
now you said something in Arabic and I
always say that just for the not yet
Muslims who tuned in they think we're
saying some code words what do you say
what is it honey did he love that's all
the facts and crazies on to Allah the
creator and then right there there's a
roller coaster effect you said I'm law
and them somebody I think this is some
arab guy thank God was a lot of law is
the one God the one that we got the one
guy yeah the God of Abraham and God of
Abraham Jesus Christ Jesus cause of
Moses all the prophets that's it that's
where I greater the Sun and the moon
over creator of everything that is this
that's a lot that's alone yes and it
just want extra note on that that it's
it's a system language to arabic aramaic
and many people they don't reflect and
they don't think that Jesus he never
spoke English he spoke Aramaic mm-hmm
and he would say Allah ha uh-huh Allah
Allah ha same God Jesus comment upon
that's the one who you're praising and
thanking thank you for clearing that up
and now you're with some of the
celebrities you were performing at
concerts your dream is to be a star oh
yeah you can cool to attract then yeah
back then these are days that we call
Julia oh yeah so we want to give the
people kind of just a taste of what you
were living and how you came to the
sweetest of sweetest of things this man
so what would give us a pair how was
things going what were you inspiring to
be were you trying to be on MTV where
you on MTV what were you wanting on and
striving to accomplish I was so striving
to be a so-called you know R&B superstar
if there's such a thing you know I was
working out of Toronto New York and Los
Angeles I worked with many different
producers and songwriters and did a few
albums as well Russell Simmons what I
didn't get to work with him he's like a
famous dancer right he's you did you
know him no I'm not personally in there
but you know I had some you know some
very good interest from one of the
prominent writers and producers from Los
Angeles it goes by the name of baby face
he's produced all of the top artists
I've heard of him babyface yeah yeah
yeah I spent a long time ago I can't
even remember his name in a long time
ago too but these names these are these
are popular figure they still are today
yeah they still owe her yeah you know I
was describing to get to the top of that
so-called leather and why for money for
fame for money for fame you know but
this is what I'm saying for me while I
was taking that journey I never ever
felt as though I was doing something
that I was totally satisfied with their
was always how can I put this I always
felt as though I was acting so part of
me was always active never been totally
real yourself yeah route to myself and
to others in in that field office odd
yeah you're putting on a show yeah mr.
Schulman against the show right but you
know like I said when I was on stage I
never really felt like I'm you know I
was being myself yeah now one day at
what age did you start to sing and you
start to get involved in the music
business um when I was about maybe 17 18
I started the you know seeing I used to
my brother was a classically trained on
the panel so I sort of likes to watch
him so I kind of learned a few skills
and a few chords on the piano but I
wasn't racing until maybe I got to about
17 18 so people told me that I had a
good voice here and started to develop
from there uh-huh so you were also i
mean from a Christian family juicing
also and acquire uh no I didn't actually
buy it used to be altar boy and I'll
think wanted to hear right every Sunday
what so were you practicing Christianity
was your family Christians were you go
into the church yes this is what always
dude every sunday at the same time not
singing not all the singing at that time
yeah are you sing on saturday hang out
at the church on Sunday oh you Scott
church on Sunday yeah I should do my
little fingers play the piano every
saturday morning yeah and it was more
less how that okay so how are you mixing
the two in what is you know are you
godly are you looking you know to like
are you religious how you're not really
is you know you got the music thing
going you're inspiring you know you're
the club I'm sure we're not going to get
into details there drinking there's all
sorts of things going on there and but
then there's the church so where you at
well i was going to church doing my
thing and then slowly came away from the
church by always had the Creator in mind
because my mother taught me about God
she didn't teach me about in having any
partners or nothing like that she's
talking about God okay so that's what
how I understood yeah okay so you were
just like most people they're born in
the family they don't question anything
and you're just feeling like this is the
right there yep now at what point did
you start to question at what point did
you decide okay you know I gotta get a
little more serious and at what point
did you start to ask the more crucial
persons like what's the purpose of life
well you know I went through quite a bit
in my lifetime where I didn't ask any of
those questions yeah you know because I
was too busy doing things that you know
I wanted to do for myself and didn't you
know always had you know but in mind but
still went on about doing my business
and just left all that the villages
stuff behind yeah but along the way a
couple of Muslim brothers stopped me in
the street and asked me if you know I
knew anything about the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon which at that time I
didn't so was this is a random and it
was yesterday what they had like add our
table no it wasn't at our table it was
just a problem just came up to my don't
know why but just came up to me in the
street los almost some approaches you
need to suppose me in the street and ask
me you know she's probably you know I'm
can I be a tongue can speak for a couple
minutes was ok so so let's take a break
now and we're going to find out what
this Muslim said to you who will be
right back
they're always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say some positive boss just hold on
to the Rope of Allah everything in this
universe real I I need a last minute the
quarter answers don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told it will fail
your marginal gossip that the Prophet
SAW solid never ever stopped a war
against anybody's from back here on the
Dean show with abdullah roll and you're
talking to us about your journey to
islam which you saw islam simply means
to acquire peace by submitting
surrendering your entire cell to the one
guy because he owns pieces you can't get
it unless you get it from the one guy
yeah so that's islam and a muslim is one
who does islam so this muslim approaches
you out of the blue and he's like what
well at first i was prepared to stand
and talk with him where were you going I
can't remember I just know was um I was
going to a rehearsal okay this distracts
going to rehearsal so I was kind of luck
in a hurry then he asked me he asked me
a few questions and then he went towards
do I know anything about the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him here and I'm
sure I told him my background was from
the Christian faith so he made reference
to the Bible and asked me how I not read
about Muhammad in the Bible Muhammad in
the Bible yeah okay I said to him no and
then I thought you know I really don't
have any time for this like most people
we all got time for yeah sorry you know
spoke a little bit morning I said look
I've got to go because I'm late yeah
that was the image oh he just dropped
the seed or sun yeah that's exactly what
you did because the fingers I've never
forgotten it yeah you know even though
it was it did not have an effect on me
at that time it's something that stayed
with me because I've never forgotten it
just like one of those spontaneous
things they have in your life and went
out a million chance that someone just
comes up to you and starts talking about
Islam mm-hmm it's okay so you leave that
off now you go you gotta go I gotta go I
gotta get this Grammy another working
for that okay what happens next
um well it's quite a bit of time as a
you know elapsed since then and I find
myself listening to a lot of conspiracy
theories documentaries and so on and so
forth but interesting informative but
they wouldn't feed him muscle at all so
remember I moved to East London I was an
islamic book shop I mean my son was
standing outside that bookshop and I
said to my son sits and you know I
really need something to feed my song
I've got so much information at home but
don't do nothing for not just need
something that's gonna feed me so at
what point where were you in your music
career now was did you have like many of
the things that that you know women
money good times will you what people
perceive as good time you were having
that I passed through that you passed
through this yeah it didn't taste the
same you got played out yeah ok so now
something in the soul is calling
yourself yeah ok now will happen um my
son you know from dinner he tell him i
said to me that look at this poster huh
and the poster said the purpose of life
it had a picture of a baby on the front
of it yeah so for that looks really
interesting so I walked into the shop oh
by the way it's part one if I walked in
the shop and I spoke to the bread aisle
and he said to me on and I showed me the
the shelf with this with the dvds it was
part two part free and I was just like
you know I want all of this because it
looks really interesting they said to me
no bra just take the first one which is
what i did i took it home i put it in
there was a lecture by a brother called
honey ya seen Holland I've seen a
purpose of life yeah okay when he
started to speak I paused it yeah I said
you know what I need to have something
to eat have a wash sit down and watch
this because this sounds like it's going
to be very slow you just happen again to
be somewhere again were so that's why so
Muslims are yeah and you see a DVD here
in front of this was some SH out there
because he had the way he had the window
it was like there was books and DVDs and
it looked very attractive yeah so I just
stopped little to it yeah and like I
said it was my son who pointed it out to
me yeah ok so now you take this you're
yearning for something more than just
material things mm-hmm just seeking the
pleasures of the body your soul is
yearning you get this purpose of life
you get home and what happened I just
knew it was going to touch me that's why
I stopped him tough what I you know
Chris about 23 hours longer I thought
you know I really need to be sitting
down relax to take all of this in and
set that down start to listen to it and
the words that you know I was hearing it
was like I was being reborn and also at
the same time it was though everything I
was hearing I already knew him it was
just laying dormant waiting to be woken
up again and yeah and I knew you know I
thought to myself yeah this is
definitely for me until he said you have
to pray five times a day this was
Shaitaan knocking on the door yeah cause
like no I don't have time for that you
know because I'm still on you know my
music thing and you know I don't have
time for that yeah so continue to listen
to it and you know I thought yeah I'd
also it definitely made it had an impact
on me but the one thing that stood in my
way was the fact that you'd have to pray
five times a day and I didn't understand
the timings by news in the morning
afternoon late afternoon and evening a
night I thought no that's best I'm can't
do that but everything else about what
he explained the purpose of life was it
something where you felt like okay
something came up on you over you with
something distal or was it something
that you use your brain and just open
your heart so your heart was ready to
take in the true and was it something
that it was intellectually stimulated
you mentally that's exactly how it was
you know it came it my mind was
listening to these words and whilst it
was it was trickling down here I could I
could you know I just knew that what I
was hearing it just it was to me it was
just it was just true it was the truth
and it was from you know it was from a
ma was a rational logical it was
rational scientific virtue cool it was
scientific he used as many examples as
he could to try and you know to shed
light on you know what people have a lot
of misconceptions about today as far as
the slab goes yeah many people can watch
this action this actually had a great
impact I mean purpose of life I think
you can go on the internet just put
holiday are seeing purpose of life and I
think it's out there people can see it
for free yeah yeah
so now you see this and now there is
some okay he explains the purpose of
life he the concept of God it's real
simple you know one guy just God all the
rights are given to the crater and not
to demo i gots meye God's and all these
other weird things so what happens now
you you need to start did you take the
the testimony of faith no no no what I
did was I kind of um delayed it for a
few weeks huh I asked my wife to did you
see like in the video where they have
less you know so many different Muslim
is the combo sunday lineup is like 20
arrows ash hadu an la illaha illa allah
la ash hadu Ana Muhammadan Abdul Abdul
Waris ooh
they all bear witness that there is no
god but God and Muhammad is the
Messenger they all except it's not I saw
that and but you see the females you
know shake on was still you know
whispering in my ears like that's not
for you man you've got more important
things to do you know that remind there
is a hadith an effective saying for the
last time I final message to the icon
from harm is it he said what when a
person is about to accept Islam the way
of submitting is running to the one guy
shake down calm today are you going to
accept Islam and leave the religion of
your forefathers you know are you gonna
become listener so was this something
like he was coming and some you know put
pressure on you you know sphere what
wore out I have to be honest the dads
didn't come from that side because I
really you know knew in my heart that
Christianity was not for me in what I
understood what I was taught what I
heard as far as this lamb goes I knew it
was truthful and it was the truth but i
was still battling yeah because i knew i
would have to change my life and I would
have to stop certain things that I was
doing and just you know become
submissive to the religion of Allah so I
delayed it but my wife I also look I'm
so busy working in the studio can you
please go back and get me maybe part 2
apart free yeah she went back there was
none her purpose of life yeah I feel
free and in part through you but when
she went back there was all gone yeah
and she got me a different a different
lecture he was called the signs of the
our signs of the hour ok mm-hmm oh but
when I listen today that's from that
French scientist that became Muslim no
that was from shake face [ __ ]
Australia all right at the time that's
where he was um I said I can watch this
this was up for about two hours long and
oh ok in between two week period I had
gone to some lectures as yeah so what
I'd listen to speakers live so you're
enticed by what is what's being
presented about Islam is making sense so
because the time is short what finally
has you come to a decision like you know
what I need to become one who is in
compliance with the crater wants to do
any
homes this is a listen to this lecture
where the brother spoke about the beast
coming up from the earth you know having
believer in your head printed in your
head or non-believer Judgment Day and so
on these are the things that just
finally made me realize there is no time
to delay anymore because I delayed like
I said for about two weeks I had you
really focusing on death def yes and
also linear Judgment Day of Judgment the
mercy of Allah you know whether he
decides whether he's going to you know
have mercy on us on that day or not and
there was no way in this world that I
could delight for another second i
remember it was twelve o'clock at night
I wanted to take my shot on the right
day my way to give it you know just I
went to do it right there on that spot
yeah and did you I couldn't because it
was trouble so what I did was I call the
brothers first week in the morning I
said to them what I have to do have to
do this now so what they did was they
invite me run to the house in the in the
evening and a humdinger you know gave
testimony faith and too much harder and
I've never looked back since we're gonna
be right back for more here on the game
show don't go nowhere I am not afraid to
stand alone if allies by my side I am
not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone
I am Not Afraid alone the D everything
the this cup is insincere submission to
the one who created because it's
following the rules of gravity by
definition this is how we can say that
Islam has been here since the very
beginning of time anywhere the Muslims
went to people embraces them in masses
countries nations and this is something
that is amazing never happen on the face
of earth where people saw a practical
way of life of being truthful and honest
making sense of everything that they do
they worship and they buy and said now
you became a Muslim and we're almost out
of time again did you have to go through
any crazy weird rituals did you have to
go get dipped in a pool what did you
have to do to become the one that has
totally consciously submitted to the one
guy what did you do um I just saw
started to read what did you have to say
Oh what is no sorry okay I'm sorry my
pivot I'm sorry the Shahada could you
forget a break okay shipped right yeah I
had to firstly was said in Arabic yeah
but when the brother translated it I had
to say that I testify that there is one
God and His Messenger is Mohammed he's
final messenger so that there's no God
where they worship except the One God
you said that and then muhammad is the
messenger here now many people don't
know when you say that that includes all
the preceding messengers Jesus Christ
Moses Abraham at their time you would
say the same shall do the same testimony
there's no god but god allah and jesus
is the messenger at that time but today
the last day final mr. problem heart
peace be upon him we don't worship Him
we don't know elevate him to God or the
right hand of God but he's just a
teacher instructor a messenger that we
follow mm-hmm on how to get close to God
so how you agree to that well certainly
what
the prayer now well this is five times a
day yeah well you know the most that was
one of the biggest battles and
challenges for me which was to actually
learn the prayer so that I could offer
it and performance it took some time now
implementing Islam the prayer the second
pillar of Islam it's like a medicine it
starts to change your life size to keep
you away from evil you now just to fast
forward did you eventually start to
implement it and how did by implementing
Islam to develop your character did you
start to leave off many of the evo vices
well the finger for me was I obviously
learned in english first yeah and those
were the most inspiring words that I
heard for a very long time and I
couldn't wait to learn Arabic to be able
to offer my slot in the language that
has been prescribed by law for us to to
offer our cellar yeah which took time
but I was in a straight way yeah you
know because that's something I had to
do so how do you feel now I feel like
you know from dealer could never stop I
feel I've been blessed I feel that all
Muslims who've been guided like if
you've been guided to Islam you it's a
blessing from Allah it's a mercy from
him and you you know I couldn't you know
one day they were not worried you shall
learn one day will not pass where you
know I'd feel naked if I if I didn't say
my prayers yeah I feel that something is
completely missing us if I didn't you
got the internal clock now time time
it's time to prayer common variable so
I'm to success I'm to survive this Oh
big five minutes take the five minutes
and just pause pop from chase in the
world get back to it what a beautiful
feeling though isn't it to know that you
know what and sometimes you don't
believe it or not I'm in the studio
working today and you know the closer
the prayer comes is the more interested
in the works game the more intense the
more focused on learning and but when i
leave you and I stop it and I said most
of right time to go make wudu ablution
yeah and get ready for prayer that is a
beautiful feeling a lot of the crater
has certainly blessed you because he
gives the world the riches to anybody
but when he loves someone he gives him
the proper understanding of the truth
and this is a proof and the testimony to
the love that Allah he's loving us but
your heart was open it was open
you let it in some people just close
they just you know they're not ready you
got to alleviate and get rid of and
eradicate all the hatred and the enmity
and this racism and then open your heart
and you did that this is amazing tell us
now now you also you left off the music
business but you're now singing just
vocal yeah just vocals no musical
instruments and like I said before when
I used to do you know that music
performances I always felt like I was
acting and what I said it whoever had
substance or not it wasn't enough yeah
and then you know I had a recording
studio I was going to sell it which I
did they had it you had your own
recording me okay you get you you what
do you do it i just got to do i sold my
musical instruments I've got quite a bit
of equipment I was left to debate
essentials before I was going to get I
was going to get rid of that for let me
just do one last song in this studio for
old times sake yeah and ended up doing
my first machine yeah which was called
none greater than the Korean time none
greater than the Creator that was my
first Monsieur now now not you got to
give us a taste now you got to give us a
taste of people who are viewing you
mentioned it and many people already in
the Muslim world know who you are can
you sing it for I'll give you a little
rendition yes please go ahead piss away
he created the universe to him belong
the heavens and the earth the everliving
he is the first he's the owner of mercy
he sent his messengers to all his
creatures of the great danger in
worshipping Allah then Allah there is
none greater than the Creator Allah
Wakeman Allah Wakeman there is none
greater than the Creator Allah wake /
awake ma sha la la Wilda thank you very
very much if somebody wants to pick up
one of your cds where can they get it
well they can go to www roll calm and on
that song you just heard is on the
patient's album a patient yeah you can
go and buy that online if you want to or
my second album which is called the
journey journey yeah there's some
beautiful nasheeds on here heartwarming
and um you know go out and support the
calls you'll see the work that i'm doing
in sha allah and this is just your voice
on these just my voice no musical
instrument wow that's amazing that's
amazing it's the mercy from allah oh
yeah believe me thank you very much
thank you very much you i like to thank
you and for sharing your story with us
and may allah continue to bless you and
keep you striding forward all the way to
Jenna paranoid youtube revolving juggle
a height / Quilici room thank you these
if anybody sees that for me those are
for you oh my gosh a lot thank you very
much you and cook and you've heard it
here several times before that there is
none great tour then the create tour
it's very simple to understand there are
so many people coming to Islam because
Islam gives you peace peace with your
create or peace within your very self
and then you can have peace with the
society everyone around you Islam is
calling you to peace God Almighty is
calling you to that which will bring you
life to be successful in this life and
not only in this life to be the best in
this life the best character the best
manners away from all sorts of evil
corruption but then you'll be successful
in this life and in the next and we're
all striving for paradise because def is
a reality and the day of judgment is
near so let's be ready let's do the good
deeds but the foundation needs to be
built on something
wrong and that foundation is that you
worship none but the create tour and not
his creation and you strive to follow
and emulate the last and final messenger
that was sent to mankind the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him thank you and
we'll see you next time here on the Dean
show until then peace he created the
universe to him along the heavens and
the earth everliving he is the first
he's the owner of mercies and his
messengers to all his creatures on the
great danger Oh worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater
then the Creator whoa there is none
greater
oh and love we ain't no
ah